all right so I'm out here on the
2010 Honda Fit and what we're doing
car is for reprogramming she didn't have
a key fob for a car she has each type of
keys and she has no key file she just
got this car about a month ago and one
of the key fob so I'm just going to
reprogram the keys real quick this is a
key fighter you can get like an Amazon
or something that we think I think we
pay about 20 bucks for it now when you
get these with the key on it they're not
cut obviously so you'll have to take
them somewhere and get them cut but they
charge fifty five dollars to program
them so anyway twenty dollars for the
five and the key and then get a cut and
then we can use the launch here and
we'll do a program on it it's probably
going to have a three program all the
keys she has one key already without the
fob and then she bought two keys she got
this key and normal key that she wants a
program so we're just got a program
these two new ones the five and then
probably have a probably have us
reprogram the other one she has usually
what it does is it'll just have your
program vault once so right now it wants
to do a little firmware upgrade
something to let it do that anyway so
this is a you know like I said I think
the average price usually is about 55 or
60 bucks to program a key might be more
to dealership I'm not sure so if you
have if you know if someone that has an
auto or a launch it's something that can
be done pretty quickly and maybe if you
know someone has one just throw them a
couple bucks and they can do it but
anyway we'll go through the process here
I'm gonna get set up and we'll go
through the process and reprogram these
keys real fast all right so this is the
this is the key that she had with the
car and you can see here if you put it
in
car starts right up and there's no
issues at all with it you can see it's
still running so when you get these keys
that are programmed and I lost them
it's like this key here it's cut it'll
fit in the ignition but what's gonna
happen when you turn it it'll start and
die see the car is running and then it
dies right away if you have this Queen
key light right here flashing and that's
because you know it's not programmed to
the ECM so that's the one with the key
fob then we have this other one that you
got it'll do the same thing you'll start
the car for a few seconds and then it
should you see their car starts dies
it's about two seconds the green lights
flashing so we're gonna fix that now so
what we're going to do is go into so
we're going to go in the Honda
put the key back in here trying to get
off a little bear here
of course you got this set up first
and we're going out of keys find the
keys on here mobilizer
all right we're gonna hit select keys
I'm gonna hit the wrong thing select
keys we're just gonna add one key right
now so it's the turn is to switch off
now it says turn to this and switch
along with the original key so we're
going to do that now it says turn D this
switch off at the 17 seconds so we're
doing that now it says turning this to
switch on with a new key within 20
seconds so we're doing that now just
turn it off within 15 seconds now just
turn it on without changing the keys or
the new keys still in the ignition on
it's asking if the immobilizer light
went off that's the green key light so
we're gonna hit yes now saying turn it
back off now it's saying turn it on with
the original key so we'll switch it back
over to the original key
now just turn the bag off okay it's a
lot of uh now it says make sure it
starts with all the keys that we
programmed which we just program one for
now
so that's turning the switch on so now
this is the new key the one that she
bought with the five and there you go
you can see it's running the immobilizer
light is off so that particular key that
we just got is programmed and then now
we'll try the factory key one more time
for the one that you got originally so
now I'll fill the floor so now we're
going to put our original key back in
does have a fob
and of course that one still looks good
so that was how you do if you're just
gonna add one key since we have three
keys total all right since we got she
found another key so since we got four
keys total we're just gonna rewrite them
all at the same time so right now we
have two that work but we're not gonna
just add one key we're gonna add two
more keys so somehow we got four keys
this car so she should never have a
problem losing the key on this car so
anyway it says how many keys you want to
register a maximum of six we're gonna
say four hit okay now it says turn this
to switch off I got a few that's going
to be a lot of on and off on and off
turn it on turn it off
now Susteren on with another key within
20 seconds turn it off turn it off
another key within 20 seconds so all I'm
doing is just going through the four
keys we have turn it off and then last
one via 4th keys to turn it on turn it
off now that's when you turn it back on
without switching the key so I got the
fourth key in there just turn it off and
then back on the immobilizer light is
off so is turning the switch off now it
says turn on with the original key
all right so saying all four keys should
be registered so let's test on this is
the original key
and you can see their mobilizers off and
it's running so I go through real quick
and check off for these that's the first
one this is the second one
you can see it's just a lot turning the
keys on and off and switching the keys
around this one works go for the third
one and I guess I'm hiding that you can
have six in the ECM at one time this car
has four so that's this one and then
this would be the last one the fourth
one all right
so these are all working jobs done for
her so you can tell you can see here if
you have an auto our launch is pretty
easy to reprogram the keys and the fobs
even if you have see you have a key five
and you lose it a lot of times you can
program the fives with Outlook skiing
tool but some of them you can't in the
launch the auto can program those so I
know not everybody has access to one of
these types of skiing tools they're
pretty expensive but if you know someone
that has one it's pretty good it's a
good it's a nice option to have on this
type of scam tool and if you're in the
st. Louis area you can contact me
through either Facebook or YouTube and I
come out and program your five or your
key for you usually charge twenty five
for that really depends on how many I
have and how far you are for where I'm
at but that is something that I can do
that's something that I do do I go
places in program I just recently
programmed a couple key files for a guy
so that is something I can come to you
and do the only thing I don't cut keys
so if you need your keys cut or
something like that I won't be able to
do that for you
got to take that to a locksmith and
they'll cut it for you but if you got a
key cut or if you got a replacement key
five you can save a lot of money call
someone like me and will come out and
reprogram it instead of take it to a
dealer another dealer it's outrageous to
get this done and anyway so that's
something I can do probably 10-15
minutes in your driveway if you live the
st. Louis area and if you do have a
problem Amazon is a good source for
those bob's or the keys the keys are a
lot cheaper too through Amazon like I
said we got this key here that's a key
fob built in with the key for $20 on the
amazon and then she had a cut to her
original key and then I just you know
you saw me reprogram it so and I think
they the locksmith won it I think a
hundred and ten for this key and the
program and cut it so she saved quite a
bit of money getting surprised at least
fifty bucks getting this on the Amazon
that having me come out
program it so anyway that's it I'm gonna
go ahead and shut the launch down and
give all the keys back to her and she'll
be on the way and this should be it
thanks for watching and like I said if
you are the st. Louis area go ahead and
contact me you through Facebook or
YouTube and I'll come out and probably
I'm 45 or Yorkie for you and anyway
thanks for watching and we'll see you on
the next one